どう違うのダイバと暴力それも分からずに
ダバと暴力を一緒にするのが今のバカ
マスコミやろ進歩を目的とした有力の
使これが松
だいい
こと全悪というものが全くはっきりして
ね混乱するの当たりじゃ
マスコミから結構よく先生が言われてる
その体罰についてこの先生なりの見解って
いうのを初心者用にもう1回お願いしても
いいですかはいえっとそう言うと日本中が
初心者じゃ
ない誰も罰さ何か知らずに体罰反対言っ
とるわねこんな非科学的な態度でええ
のそれが子供に影響して子供は非科学的
教育を受けるもんで成果が出ない体罰
は進歩を目的とした有力の行使本来なら
自分で勝手に進歩すりゃええのにその能力
がまだなかったりサボってその能力を身に
つけなかったりした
やつひっぱたきは痛い痛いのは嫌嫌だから
頑張る頑張らんとまた次引っ張ったかれる
からやねどから進歩する
進歩を目的とした有力の
行使これが体罰
だいい
ことな体罰は前
ないだからね体罰の当たり前だった時代
我々の時代やまだ戦後やけども罰当たり前
やって学校
でその時に連帯責任なんてよ取らされたよ
ね1人悪いことしたやつはそいつをみんな
が止めなかったからみんな悪いとか言って
なずらっと並ばされてパンパン
パンパンパン叩かれてで分かったか分かり
ました言うとまだ分かってないとか言って
ね今度職員室の前に連れて行かれるこ職員
室の前にずらっと並んでたっとるとな通
てく先生がみんな引っぱっ
てくなんか悪いことしたやろ
それやって
ね今度次にまた悪いことをし
てなんかで他のことでひっぱたか
れるそそうしたらなんとね俺が小学校の頃
だ
よひっぱたいた先生に向かってね
ありがとうございましたって言ったよ我れ
ながらびっくりしたよあれ
はでどうしてそんなことが言えるんや
そいつはその前にやられた体罰によって
自分が進歩したという実感があるんだ結局
後から考えてみたら俺を進歩させるために
あれ体罰やったなという風に思えるんや
素直に考えるだからその次やられた時も
これは俺を進歩させようとしとると思える
んやだから心の底からだよありがとう
ございましたと言っきはああいつはいい点
やろうなって邪悪な目を持ってを言っとる
にはない本当に心からありがとうござい
ましたと言え
てマスコミとかだと体罰の中に暴力が含ま
れる暴力がシンプルに良くないって批判が
ま一番多いかと思うんですけどその点に
ついてはどう考えですかどう違うのダイバ
暴力
はそれも分からずにタイ暴力を一緒にする
のが今のマスコミやろだからゴミなんだ
あいつらね自分たちが偉いと思っとるから
みんな上から
メス自分たちの言ったことは正しいのに
あいつ反対しやがってけしからんやつは
やっちまえていうのが上から目線の弱い
人間的に非常に弱い人間のやることない
それが体罰と暴力の違いっていうのは
目的暴力は
自分の利益のためにやるやろ体罰
はやられる方の利益のためにやるんだ自分
になんか利益
あるないよ
ね
時々ヒステリックな体罰をやれ人がおるや
ん弱いやつに決まっとるんあいつは自分の
不安を消すために体罰やっとるだからあれ
は遺憾体罰な
子供が途中で必ず言い出すじゃん何のため
に勉強すんのよとお前のためだというそれ
がどうどうして自分のためになるのかた
もう言えんわねいい会社に入れるかぐらい
東大に入って三菱に入ってそれなことしか
言えん
のそれがどなぜいいのよということになっ
ちゃうわね争に勝ったというのねところが
学校では競争はいかんて言っとるは
な混乱すんの当たり前
じゃん全悪というものが全くはっきりして
ない進歩とは何かも知らん当然どうやっ
たら進歩するかもしらんただその場の現象
だけその場子供が喜んだらええことその場
子供が嫌がったら悪いこと
これあかんぼの状態じゃないこれ教育に
なってないよねだから子供に教えておいて
やらんといかんのは進歩の能力をどうやっ
て身につつけるかない子供に進歩の能力を
身につけさしてやりさえすればあ自分で
やるよ実的
に実績がええん
やろ
なあJA
[音楽]